[Musique]
pour être entendu il vaut mieux être
plusieurs rapports le même message c'est
tout l'intérêt de former un groupe
parlementaire les députés doivent être
au minimum 15 pour pouvoir peser
davantage dans l'examen des lois mais
aussi faire leur place dans le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée je vous
explique il existe aujourd'hui 10
groupes parlementaires tous doivent
choisir entre majorité présidentielle et
opposition les députés qui ne font
partie d'aucun d'entre eux sont désignés
comme non inscrits
l'Assemblée nationale leur met à
disposition des locaux leur permet de
recruter des collaborateurs et leur
octroie une dotation financière en
fonction de leur effectif
un groupe parlementaire c'est la
garantie de peser au sein du bureau de
l'Assemblée il est composé du président
et des vice-président des questeurs et
des secrétaires de l'assemblée il se
doit d'être représentative du rapport de
force dans l'hémicycle
appartenir à un groupe c'est aussi
participer à l'organisation du travail
parlementaire mais aussi avoir un rôle
plus important à jouer aux différents
stades de l'examen d'une loi
les présidents des groupes
parlementaires participent à la
Conférence des Présidents son rôle fixé
entre autres l'ordre du jour des séances
parlementaires les groupes obtiennent
aussi des sièges au sein des commissions
parlementaires proportionnellement à
leur effectif avantage majeur puisque
c'est en commission que sont préparés
les textes avant l'examen dans
l'hémicycle pas de travail parlementaire
sans pouvoir s'exprimer au sein de
l'hémicycle et c'est là tout l'avantage
d'appartenir un groupe parlementaire
pendant l'examen d'un texte 60% du temps
de parole va à l'opposition et 40% à la
majorité
cet espace d'expression est réparti
proportionnellement au poids de chaque
groupe même principe de proportionnalité
pour le nombre de questions posées au
gouvernement appartenir à un groupe
donne également accès à ce que l'on
appelle une niche parlementaire
c'est-à-dire une journée réservée chaque
mois au groupe d'opposition qui à tour
de rôle définissent eux même l'ordre du
jour c'est l'opportunité pour eux de
discuter dans l'hémicycle et de mettre
aux voix des sujets qu'ils défendent ils
peuvent même proposer la création d'une
commission d'enquête parlementaire pour
contrôler l'action du gouvernement
[Musique]